see s math side of things is touching
upon a second of our talks today in
astrophysics here machine learning time
domain for time domain astrophysics and
the interesting part about this is it's
really going to answer one of the
questions it's an approach to into one
of the questions that Eric brought up in
the previous talk which is what do you
do when you have sparse incomplete data
from a survey like LSST when you're
trying to sort through these millions
projects every single so Josh thank you
Peter and thanks to the Simons Institute
and to the Moore and the sloan
Foundation's for their support in the
past and currently I think it's worth
saying at the outset that the
fundamental reason why we actually do
the work we do to innovate on the
algorithmic side and computationally is
to do novel science in this case it'll
be in astrophysics but where you're
going to hear throughout the week is a
broad interest in using these tools and
building new tools to do some novel work
in the physical domains we also use this
because of the fire hose that you just
heard about in the previous talk just to
be able to handle of that onslaught and
be able to make the best use of the data
that's coming at us and I think
increasingly what we're seeing is that
because this is a very powerful set of
tools ie machine learning in astronomy
it's also becoming a competitive
advantage for the groups that know how
to how to use it let me start off with
you know what is probably the most
exciting discovery of the last decade if
not longer in astrophysics which brings
together actually the physics community
and the astrophysics community around
the so called merging neutron star
events you're gonna hear a lot about
this from Alessandra and Muncie later
today so I don't want to harp on it but
use it really as a launching off point
the point of departure for saying that
there are some very big prizes
in understanding the the universe and
the connection of the gravitational wave
universe with the electromagnetic
universe and we're just starting to see
this era start up and so the discovery
last last summer and the announcements
that you heard about just over the last
couple of months have really emphasized
to many of us the importance of being
able to do real-time inference and
discovery
not just because if you don't find it
you don't get to do good science
afterwards but because there's many
other groups working on this and in fact
that's perhaps best shown with this
paper here which has three thousand six
hundred and seventy seven authors there
are a lot of people involved in this
work all sort of taking different facets
around what is fundamentally just a
single event so you hear a lot more
about that event and its importance and
its implications later on but I think
this event really is a great reason for
us to recognize that we need to do
discovery on images as you heard about
in the previous talk and you heard about
for those of you there that were at the
bootcamp before on the left-hand side
you know are these real or spurious
images that's an important question and
then we need to do inference so if you
look at the graph on the right hand side
this is what we call a light curve in
astronomy parlance it's basically
brightness on the y-axis and time on the
on the x-axis and the question is is it
worth when you look at this spending
time on this object not just with the
instrument that's doing the discovery
but with other follow-up facilities that
are potentially more sensitive or can
look at it in a different wavelength or
take a spectrum to understand perhaps
the chemical composition of this of this
object so that's the question that we
asked and if it wasn't clear from Eric's
talk it's probably worth saying that if
you have sufficient sensitivity every
single thing in the sky changes it
changes its color it changes its
brightness it changes its position on
the sky if you look hard enough
and so while oftentimes we focus on the
things that are most
fantastic the biggest explosions that
just become so obvious they're as bright
as their whole host galaxy there are
lots more subtle objects that are only
changing at the few percent level or
less that have some very interesting
facets to them that many groups want to
follow up what you see on the right-hand
side is also a light curve that's pretty
rich you see it's a regularly sampled
you can't really see the the fact that
some of these data points are noisy but
oftentimes some of the most exciting
science comes out when you only have one
or two data points on a new object as
it's being born or as it's just starting
to evolve and so a really important
question that we have to wind up asking
again in the real-time context is if we
only have a few data points do we
observe that object and continue observe
that object and keep burning resources
so the agenda in my talk today really
geared for non astronomers to get
somewhat up to speed in the state of
machine learning and the time domain
astronomy world is to introduce to you
the different ways in which we view the
time domain and real time types of
inference with the lens not just as
astronomers but people who are applying
and potentially even innovating on some
of the tools to get better science out
and I hope at the end to present some
interesting challenges and maybe even
some right places to start for the non
astronomers in the room from a
collaborative perspective so I'll start
with just some of the constraints and
some of the things that we think about
when we're building some of these
computational systems and working on
some of our algorithms I'll talk about
discovery and this has been discussed
both in the previous talk and was also
done in the bootcamp so I'll go over
that part pretty quickly and focus a lot
on inference so the real-time part of
the inference so what is this object I
only have a few data points what do I do
next and then the retrospective not just
looking at a single object but looking
at large catalogs of objects I mean the
time to mean to try to figure out how I
get good science out and then I'll end
with
some of those challenges and open
questions just a level set what I'll
present here something that doesn't look
at all like the scientific method but is
actually the way in which astronomers
work is you do lots of planning an
acquisition of data so what you heard
about in LSST well you'll see about ztf
is trying to figure out the ways in
which you wind up observing the sky so
this is what's often called the cadence
so how often do you repeat a certain
observation of the same part of the sky
and there's obviously a trade-off if you
don't go back to the same part of the
sky then you're gonna miss objects that
are changing rapidly but it means then
you have the opportunity to survey a
larger part of the sky so there is
always some biases in a positive way of
what type of science people are trying
to get at from that perspective it's you
know allocating telescope resources it's
deciding how to move the data around etc
the next part which I won't spend much
time on either as well he's in the
cataloging characterisation you heard
about from Eric's talk how LSST is going
to be basically cataloging potentially
interesting places on the sky and maybe
even telling you a little bit about the
properties of those objects on the sky
so how do you extract from an image of
the sky how do you extract metadata
metadata like the brightness and that's
a non-trivial exercise and it needs to
be done right and well certainly at
scale associating that data with other
other catalogs is important and against
storage and retrieval of that in making
that efficient and useful for
communities is quite important
instead what I'll focus on is really
next part is in the discovery which is
the question is this source in my
catalog real or not and you know what is
the source even potentially interesting
for me to spend time on and you know
what's the appropriate science that I
could potentially get out of this if I
decided to keep going and start asking
more questions of this data and I make
the distinction by the way between
cataloging and discovery because if you
put something in your database it does
mean you've recognized that it's
interesting and for me sort of the best
exemplars of this comes from a catalogue
from about 400 years ago from Galileo
who was observing and discovering the
Galilean moons and you can see basically
the actual photograph of a part of that
journal
there's Jupiter there there's three of
the Galilean moons and we now know on
that day that Jupiter was actually at
the position that's listed as a fixed
star and about two weeks later Galileo
came back and noticed that that fixed
star had kind of moved but didn't really
recognize that that was actually another
planet so it was about 150 years later
that Jupiter sorry Neptune was actually
discovered so I find this fascinating
and protect potentially Tsar the best
sort of well known example in in science
of cataloguing something really
important but not recognising its
importance right so I try to make that
distinction I argue that if Galileo had
found Neptune he would have been very
famous okay we've got some very good so
what comes after discovery is inference
so I now know this object is interesting
I now know it's real what is this source
is this like something we've seen before
is it not if we're right about the
classification what is it going to look
like the next time I observe and then
the last part of that is what's the next
action this is the Federation that came
up in some of the discussion after the
last talk is this source important
enough to spend more resources on it and
what is it that I actually want to do
with it
and more importantly perhaps given the
sociology of the Astronomy community is
can I convince my friends and
collaborators and enemies to actually
stop observing what they're looking at
because my object is more important than
your object and we still very much focus
from a real-time perspective on
individual objects and I'll try to
emphasize for you in just a little bit
why why that why that's so and then the
last part of that of course is if you
then have that
hypothesis about what what you should be
doing next you go and you plan you get
more data alright and so this cycle sort
of continues on and on alright so let me
sort of give you four different facets
of the things that we're trying to
optimize over because in the end we're
talking about machine learning we're
talking about some sort of optimization
and unfortunately this is not you know a
loss function that I can trivially write
down and then I just throw whatever
mechanics I have at it to get to get the
right answer some of this stuff is a
little bit softer but I wanted to tell
you a little bit about the ways that we
we think about this and are motivated by
it number one is something I think you
all know which is that experts don't
scale astronomers haven't quite figured
that out yet so this picture from the
1890s of a bunch of so-called computers
looking at lots of images when astronomy
had a big data problem lots of images
coming out with telescopes was hire and
train people to just look at data right
this is what I call that just hire more
grad students syndrome which is what
many of us have been told for years even
the time to mean that if you have more
data you just need to get more grad
students to look at that data that
obviously doesn't scale both in sort of
the sheer numbers but if we're also
interested in some of these real time
applications where an image is taken and
then 60 seconds later you need to take
another action based on those images
people aren't that fast and from another
perspective which is probably even the
most damning is that people are pretty
subjective right and so if we want to do
this in an objective way doesn't mean
that there won't be biases you want to
be able to do what it is that these
people are doing on the right
programmatically and do it
systematically at least where you can
codify and you conversion what it is
that they're doing another facet which I
think has been sort of danced around a
little bit when we talk about the LSST
firehose is that we're now entering this
age of what I'll call cheap discovery
where we're going to be getting
literally ten million transient alerts
per night from LSST and sort of maybe an
order of magnitude less from ztf
starting next week
but we have a very very
expensive follow-up to get sort of the
best and most novel science out of that
the changing sky we have to use these
facilities like the Hubble Space
Telescope like the James Webb Space
Telescope these are all sort of
billion-dollar plus level facilities and
those resources that you can imagine are
very precious and they're massively
oversubscribed everybody wants to be
using these facilities and it's
extremely expensive for them to do that
so there's an opportunity cost because
when you do your science it means
somebody else isn't doing their science
and that's kind of interesting from a
systemic perspective there's also the
people opportunity cost as well it
actually caused energy and people to
actually spend time getting these
observations prepared and then there's
these sort of interesting questions
around that the kind of false positives
right if I'm trying to do tremely novel
science how often should I be using one
of these billion-dollar facilities and
just observing a place in the sky where
they're actually good science doesn't
come out and oftentimes you wind up
being more conservative and requiring a
guarantee scientific payout before you
actually do any speculative work on
these on these big facilities another
facet sorry what's that you could well
discovery per or dollars per discovery
would be an interesting number to look
at I'd argue that it's actually getting
cheaper if Ellis if each one of those is
equally interesting
you could argue and again because LSST
wasn't designed to do time domain it was
designed to do other science in the
static sky I'd argue that's a very very
cheap use of resources to sort of
piggyback off of the static sky science
and then there's the kind of rome's
phalion challenge which is trying to
optimize over the known knowns so
there's some bread-and-butter science
that you could get out of doing time
domain the unknown unknowns and then
stuff in the middle like you know things
that you have theoretical models for but
you haven't yet seen like the known
unknowns and what's interesting is that
this plot is I know
ten years older so the curve that you
see for the neutron star neutron star
mergers is approximately correct just
from the theoretical perspective of what
we expected to see
following a neutron star neutron star
merger now I call this sort of more of a
known known but before I used to Herald
that one as a you know known unknown but
there's stuff that are unknown unknowns
and by definition I can't put them on
this plot so you see the time scales
over which big explosive events wind up
proceeding there's some really other
interesting things that wind up
happening even on shorter time scales
that are shown here and I'll emphasize
those a little bit later on so another
aspect of this runs felon challenge is
the small number of labels right so in
in a huge amount of the machine learning
literature there is this sort of
implicit assumption that I have lots and
lots of data from at least from a
supervised perspective to be able to
build these models right so if you want
to build a good image classify or just
get more images and get a whole bunch of
people to label them like yet the
flicker level or do it implicitly
through Google searches and things like
that
in astronomy we don't have that many
labels so for things that were really
interested in we only have one exemplar
of a real object that is a neutron star
a neutron star merger one we've got
theoretical models of a whole bunch of
those with different inputs but for some
of these we really only have dozens or
maybe hundreds at best or maybe
thousands as we're entering into this L
assist here so we're really you know
even though it's a big data sort of
firehose from a labeling perspective
it's still very much a small data
problem in the last is that you know
it's all well and good to have some
plots that show how you have a you know
sort of better false positive versus
false negative curve than somebody else
in retrospect these systems that involve
machine learning that are going to be
put into place for astronomy have to be
done with robust systems that actually
work in real time and often times one of
the biggest challenges we have is not
on the algorithmic side it's not on you
know being able to produce those plots
in retrospect it's being able to stand
up robust systems that work at scale
that can ingest this firehose and
produce results that people can wind up
accepting and using and then moving on
into that value chain of inference and
so for those that haven't read this yet
this is one of my favorite papers in
machine learning it has no equations in
it it just sort of highlights all the
different bugaboos of what it means to
build a real robust functioning system
that involves machine learning and how
different that is even from just best
software engineering practices so forget
about the fact that astronomers are not
trained as software engineers we're
certainly not trained in general as
being able to build and stand up and
maintain and innovate these very
large-scale systems so that's sort of
some of the constraints and some of the
concerns that we have as we start
thinking about bringing machine learning
into into our world I want to now touch
it a little bit now on discovery so that
that facet of I've got something in my
database is this interesting is it real
and what should I do next with it you've
already seen real bogus mentioned in the
previous talk you see kind of the bad
subtractions on the top is we're trying
to find new objects and the real good
subtractions on the bottom it's a little
bit like kind of Anna Anna Karenina
right where all the bogus detection czar
all different than each other and all
the real ones are all similar to each
other but unfortunately state-of-the-art
puts us at about a thousand of one or
maybe we're getting down to a few
hundred to one of this of this needle in
a haystack
that is for every real object in a real
image that we wind up taking of the sky
there are hundreds of bogus detection so
we have to find these real ones in in
the face of quite a large number of
bogus detections and what's nice is that
if we can build a real-time framework to
identify what's real and what's not
we get some really nice things out of
that right it will be fast because it's
just algorithmic implementation
embarrassingly parallel because every
single object we can ask that question
transparent in the sense that we can
know why we got the answer we got so if
you're doing it at random forest context
you can literally follow down the
different trees and figure out why you
got that answer it's deterministic so
given the same data you get the same
answer and like with people and it's
version Abul so I can keep on upgrading
it if I need to go back and reproduce
what I had before I at least have a
fighting chance at that what we found in
some of the early work on building a
real bogus detector for real systems was
that it was a very hard problem based on
features that we derived out of the
images and the subtraction images we got
of order 75 or those first of all that's
a bit of a computational challenge
because some of those features are
expensive to construct but then we also
went up realizing that they're only
really a few algorithms that actually
did well on the same input feature space
and in particular we found that random
forest was doing extremely well relative
to all the others gave him the same
feature set and so we wind up
implementing this and sticking this in
to a real pipeline that was run up at
LPL as part of as part of PTF and what
happened is every time a new transient
or new object was cataloged it would
wind up getting scored in a real bogus
sense from 0 to 1 and then depending
upon where you make your cut of what you
call real and what you call not real you
wind up basically pushing this into
downstream systems to be followed up and
potentially even looked at by people one
of the things that for those over at the
bootcamp saw and the astronomers already
know about this is this great discovery
that was done by Peter which I'll call
ml assisted in the sense that a real
bogus classifier was applied to this
incoming data stream on new images that
were coming off
PTF and about 11 hours after explosion
PTF went up observing and cataloging and
then Peter went up noting that one of
the highest-ranked real bogus objects
from the from the catalog was actually a
very young supernova that turned out to
be the nearest type 1a supernova in more
than three decades so only a few people
you know in the history of mankind have
observed supernovae this close by and
this early and have been the discoverer
so I was very happy to see that Peter
changed his business card just so
everyone knew how important that was but
there's a student under that fingernail
there but what's what's more important
and this supernova by the way would wind
up rising in brightness to the point
where if you had binoculars you could
have observed it with it with basically
through those binoculars just absolutely
stunning so it was eventually found and
could have been seen by astronomers
worldwide but because it was found so
early we were able to do as a community
a lot of really interesting science that
we hadn't been able to do in the decades
before that get spectra get more
observations of it and a paper that I
worked on with Peter and a few others in
the room was basically ruling out
possible progenitors the things that
make those supernovae so everything in
green and all the other colors were
excluded because of the lack of
detections of certain characteristic
signatures that we could have seen and
that left behind essentially only
compact objects is the only viable
candidates so don't it doesn't matter
that you know all the different plots
what they all mean up here just to point
out though that because we were able to
get on so early to this object and
recognize its importance we're able to
do some novel science with that so this
idea of building real bogus is really
kind of flourished and as Danny talked
about and this is one of one of his
slides from his bootcamp
discussion is that this was used in the
dark energy camera sir
they particularly around finding
supernovae and so there they wind up
building another real bogus detector and
they set a different threshold between
zero and one and depending upon whether
you're above or below that threshold you
wound up getting what is essentially
kind of world-class false positive false
negative rates so getting down to MDR
means miss detection rate meaning that
if you set your threshold criteria that
at 0.5 around 4 percent of the new
candidates that you wind up having in
your catalog you wind up not identifying
as real but that means that your false
positive rate is also extremely low
right so you see where this trade-off is
only about 2 percent you would say are
real when they're actually not now the
nice thing is if you keep on coming back
to different the same part of the sky
you wind up seeing the evolution of this
real bogus score and objects that are
getting brighter in this guy generally
will end up getting a more favorable
real bogus score over time so this has
now become cottage industry and
essentially every time domain survey
that is looking at images is has their
own sort of flavor in their own approach
and their own training data for being
able to identify and do discovery
effectively in real time so I'd say
while there's probably still a little
bit of blood to squeeze out of the stone
if you look at this plot on the right
hand side I we can't get much better
than this so maybe we get down a sort of
factor of two or something like that and
miss detection rate but just to
emphasize that this isn't just a
theoretical exercise on existing old
data these are being put into practice
in real time systems we talked a little
bit more about real time inference as
part of the and by the way you know
please stop me if you have any questions
I'm happy to take them in real time yeah
so I was only joking I'm not taking any
questions
so when you so if it's to two percent
false positive rate
that still means like a thirty percent
of the things that you're saying are
real or attack bogus because that there
were a hundred times more focus outlets
yeah so if you do them if you do the
math you're you're actually saying that
and this is why you need to pull this
number way way down oftentimes most
people won't start observing and doing
follow-up until there's multiple real
detection zhh in the same place of the
sky or you're willing to you know if
it's a nearby galaxy ask sort of from a
query perspective is there something
which is really new which is just only
got one detection it looks like it's
real and it's near one of those galaxies
in that case you might be willing to put
your neck out and actually start
observing with other telescope
facilities the other thing you can do is
that's just where the threshold is and
in principle that's where the grey areas
if you want to be extremely confident in
what you actually calls really even with
a single detection you can just require
that your your Tau in this case to be
very very close to one and so that's
really kind of a measure of probability
I don't know how well calibrated that is
for the DES survey of it if it's a if
it's at 0.5 whether it's really 50/50
real or not but that's one way you can
gain confidence and cut down the number
of sort of follow-ups after that yeah
this is just photo metrically based as
in sort of what do you mean by that
spectra yeah right correct so this would
be the launching off point to get
spectra so these are just based on the
images and the preceding images for that
part of the sky spectroscopic
information is expensive
that's thank you for saying that
spectroscopic information is extremely
expensive typically that's only done on
one object or only a handful of objects
and you typically need large telescopes
to do it and has to be a pointed
observation here's about in general for
us for physics what is the real cost of
discarding the data so if you are taking
some I'm not saying black box but
something that you might know how the
process works and you threw out some
real signals how no it's fine thing to
talk about now it's a great question so
for those in here how bad is it to throw
out you know real signals that you just
miss classified to think effectively
unlike in particle physics where we you
know we really can't save all the data
as it's coming off of an accelerator and
you have to make choices essentially in
very real time about whether I save this
event or I don't save this event
astronomers at least are in a mode even
in the LSST era where every photon is
sacred and we save everything now it
goes into a database but and in
principle if that part of the sky
becomes interesting eventually we then
have a essentially a fossil record from
our databases of what we had said before
and what was there before so we're not
really throwing that out there are
interesting questions about
accessibility to those databases and
whether that's really kind of a dev null
you know in all practical terms or
whether that's something that people can
actually mine I would generally argue
that most people are not mining previous
surveys and their data effectively but
when you do you often get you know lots
and lots of prizes about what was
happening in that part of the sky before
you observe there
like you're not discarding business
you're not discarding them but you're
again you're it's sort of a decision
process of I've got this huge fire hose
I've got to somehow make that into like
a little nice stream of things that I
can handle and I'm not gonna throw out
all the water that's in the fire hose
that I'm not dealing with I'm only going
to deal with the things that I really
like but because we're often interested
in the changing sky and rapid timescales
and the most interesting observations
that we can take or ones that come you
know immediately after discovery it
doesn't help me much if I go back into
my catalogue a year later and say oh
there was a really cool thing that was
happening too bad because most of the
objects if you go back to my light curve
plot of the known unknowns and the known
knowns most of those things eventually
disappear and so if you miss it it's
pretty much gone
so from a real-time inference
perspective just quickly what we were
able to do is put a very rudimentary
classifier in the next step which is
this is an interesting source what is
that potential source we had sort of you
know three high-level types is it a
variable star of some sort
is it a transient is something that's
changing explosively or is it a rock in
our own in our own solar system ie an
asteroid or so and then there's
subclasses beyond that we didn't do a
great job of and this is a confusion
matrix for those that know about that
basically you'd like to see all your
power up to one on the diagonal and all
the off-diagonal powers
misclassifications we didn't do a great
job with this but we did show that you
could use external databases effectively
in real time to get some notion of what
this object was which gave a little bit
of indication for those working on that
survey this would be worth this would be
worth looking at and again a big part of
what we try to do is not just do this on
paper but do it in practice and so we
got to the point where this classifier
was acting as a person and having
conversations in the same effective chat
room against with other people and this
is what we call the PTF robot and in
this case it was saying i think this is
a supernova or nova or some explosive
transient of some sort and then it
turned out this turned out to be a very
interesting object which led to a paper
in nature where actually we had missed
it but there was some burbling before
this actual explosive event which was
really important find for supernovae to
be able to see some pre supernova
activity so again we got to the point I
wouldn't say where we had great results
or it was very accurate but we least
spent some time in trying to make sure
that this got into production this isn't
just in the optical domain we've done
similar things of being able to do
real-time inference in in the gamma-ray
sky on objects that I've spent a bunch
of time on these things called
gamma-ray bursts and these are basically
short-lived blasts of high-energy
like gamma rays and x-rays that come
from a random place in the sky what you
see on the left-hand side is a depiction
of the static gamma-ray sky essentially
this is the entire sky if you looked out
with gamma-ray eyes and then you see a
burst that lasts for five seconds or so
and it briefly swamps the entire
universe in in gamma rays so these are
very very bright events difficult to
localize on the sky but they don't just
produce gamma rays they also wind up
producing optical light after that and
these are the brightest optical sources
in the universe much brighter than
quasars much brighter than pretty much
any type of supernova you could ever
imagine you see the relative brightness
on the y axis here in log scale in power
so some of the brightest gamma-ray
bursts afterglow as they're called are
just you know swamp everything else as
well in the optical sky and what's great
about that is we can see these events to
the edge of the observable universe and
if we can recognize that we have an
object that can be observed at the edge
of the observable universe with large
telescopes we can get spectra for
instance of these afterglow
and they act as sort of lighthouses and
we can learn a lot about the the very
early universe using those events as
probes if only we observe them in the
first few hours after they've happened
so the mechanism the progenitors that
lead to these things the ones that are
very bright are basically very large
massive stars that wind up collapsing
probably to a black hole think of these
as sort of beyond supernovae which went
up collapsing other types of objects and
then the actual physics of what produces
this light are basically relativistic
shocks that are emitted that are moving
you know very very close to the speed of
light and have a tremendous amount of
energy and that energy the kinetic
energy is released as these as these
shocks wind up happening so with what
you'd like to do is be able to take the
information not from ground-based
observatories which have a hard time
observing gamma-ray light but from the
satellites that wind up discovering
these things
and inferring whether the objects you
have are at high redshift so very very
high distance very faraway objects and
this is also a hard problem and what we
wind up looking at is whether we could
take and you can probably see right here
there's only a few objects in red that
are these very high redshift objects
that we'd like to follow up with our big
facilities and the ones in black are the
ones whose red shifts we know are not
very high and the ones in gray are ones
we don't know we don't know the answers
to and there's just not that many of
those so the question is could we take
the immediately available data and make
a prediction of whether something is
high rich redshift or not and the answer
is really no as you can probably see it
might be a little bit difficult there's
almost no way to pick the red points out
of the other points but now we have
multiple features that we can try to use
to try to improve it and what we did is
we said well if we can't say yes or no
this thing is definitely a high redshift
or not can we arrange a new object to
say if I have an X amount of observing
time to follow up is it worth doing or
not which is a slightly a slightly
harder question to ask but we wind up
finding that if we only follow up 20% of
the ones that we are sort of rank order
and say are the highest redshift then
60% of those will wind up being at high
redshift so this is a you know big
impurity big precision recall problem
but the area under that curve relative
to random is actually nonzero so this is
actually a very useful tool that were
able to build and deploy and we only did
it with only basically 600 events and
talk about small numbers of labels we
only had 17 objects that we could train
on so getting you know guarantees or at
least trying to convince ourselves that
we weren't overfitting on the data it
was where we spent most of our time okay
let me transition now to large-scale
aggregate inference not on individual
objects necessarily in real time but in
the time domain over a large
logs of sources yeah with real follow-up
or would synthetic read perspective we
for a year or two we're publishing
whether we think something is high
redshift or not you know we had a hard
time actually just determining whether
we were right with this calibrated curve
but certainly there were a few that we
thought were high redshift which weren't
and it was the other way around but this
wasn't actually a very well used tool to
be honest in the community and we wound
up shutting it down so this is an
example of something that worked really
well on paper but potentially not very
well in practice what what data is going
into so this is data that's just
available um for those that know about
it from the Swift satellite so when one
of these satellites winds up discovering
a gamma-ray burst they send down a whole
telemetry of stuff like where it is in
the sky how bright it was how long it
lasted and some other information about
the rudimentary spectrum so I think
there are eight or ten features that
went into this no no this is literally
just the first packet that comes down
from Swift what can we say about it
without knowing anything about what's
detected and UV OTE or even X or T okay
so this is a picture of the variable sky
as viewed by the southern hemisphere at
least and you notice the big hole up in
the top left there and each one of these
points looks a lot like that light curve
in the top left which is basically time
on the x-axis and brightness on the
y-axis and the question again is you
know is this object which looks kind of
nasty and looks sort of random worth
spending time on from a follow-up
perspective and there was a survey that
was published a number of years ago that
had 50,000 variable stars of the sky and
there were only about 800 of those that
had bonafide classifications across
about 25 26 different classes of
variable stars and we asked the question
could we use that data to basically get
a good classifications that were
probabilistically determined from that
from that survey so we did you know what
we sort of generally will do when we do
a machine learning approaches the
old-school thing we make this a new
supervised problem we take that very
ratty
time series data turn it into a
supervised classification problem where
we just do features and so we produced
about 75 features from that using
unordered statistics like variability
metrics ordered statistics and doing
periodic grams etc and then even context
metric so where is this on the sky what
color is it etc and with that we were
able to produce what is and was the sort
of best in class where we wound up being
able to very reliably and with
calibrated probabilities determine over
these many classes what a source was so
if you gave us a source that wasn't part
of our training data and you asked us to
label it we were able to show what its
class was and they were able to do some
follow-up observations of that source to
actually prove for a minority subset of
those that the classifications were
actually were actually correct and we
produced what I think is one of the
first probabilistic catalogues of
variable stars which we made accessible
to the to the world where we sort of let
people traverse through the the sort of
taxonomy of variable stars click on
things and then order them by the
different probabilities of whether they
belong to that class or not so you can
see sort of that blue curve there is the
probability and then on the right hand
side you wind up seeing essentially the
probability that these belong to
different classes so I'm having
probabilistic are then we made it social
so Facebook would bias that didn't work
either and so you know what we're able
to do is basically produce these this
catalog and what we've done since then
is work on a system which we call
caesium which allows not just us but
many other people to basically build
their own
survey classifiers over large amounts of
time series data and we did this you
know around astronomy but we try to make
this in a domain agnostic way so that
you could actually use this on any sort
of domain that had time series data so
this is still a work in progress but
we're now actually starting to be able
to use this for new surveys as they come
online and rather than building sort of
one-off purpose-built
infrastructure we're getting to build a
whole bunch and make use of a whole
bunch of subsystems in these
architectures that you know kind of use
some of the modern software practices
now again one of the things I want to
emphasize is that building probabilistic
catalogs and making websites and stuff
is cool but our main focus of doing this
is to be able to do novel science and so
what we try to do in my group was take
that probabilistic catalog and then ask
interesting questions of that and then
do follow-up so for instance what we're
able to do is look for very strange
types of objects called our core borer
or DUI / stars and cutting to the chase
with follow-up observations with spectra
of only about 20 of our candidates eight
of them wound up being new discoveries
of these very very rare stars in a
catalog that had been around for 10
years and one of the stars was almost as
bright as you could see with the naked
eye and was probably known by the
Babylonians and here we're able to do
this using machine learning to help us
basically hone in on the probable
objects very very low purity of the
sample but very high efficiency of
discovery yeah going to the catalogs and
surveys there any sources of bias less
high from southern hemisphere advice
that's a great question and something we
sort of try to grapple with you don't
know there is a there is a bias in the
sense that it was taken by a single
telescope in a certain filter and it was
taken with a certain cadence so we're
certainly biased in that survey against
finding objects that change very rapidly
and go away that's one bias so you don't
see any of those in the sample they
spend a lot of time in the Galactic
plane and there's certainly a
distribution
of variable star types that are
different in the Galactic plane than
they are off the Galactic plane and
we're trying to figure out how you could
sort of disentangle almost a prior of
what you would expect that distribution
over those 26 classes to be so that
instead you could wind up producing some
sort of posterior that people could then
dial in whatever their biases were and
get different probabilities our yeah the
Magellanic Clouds are there and we don't
have those in the northern hemisphere
etc so yes certainly there are biases in
that which is why there is some
difficulty which I'll highlight at the
end of taking that you know entire
classification machinery in that model
exactly and then applying it to another
survey another survey taken of the same
part of the sky would discover and would
have in its catalog a different
distribution of variable stars the other
thing we did is find highly eccentric
detached eclipsing binaries which
allowed us to put with again follow-up
observations with high resolution
spectroscopy of the stars that we found
on the mass radius relation of stars
which is pretty fundamental thing that
you'd like to know this is actually hard
to find stars where you can actually do
this but we were able to find a number
of those and again we use that that
catalog is a launching off point to do
two new novel science so those became
science papers in and of themselves and
the last thing that we've done in this
field is something that's I think still
pretty bizarre and I'm still coming to
terms with this is the idea of looking
at a light curve like the ones I've
shown you and trying to infer the
fundamental properties of those objects
that you would only get traditionally
from spectra so what is the temperature
of that object what's its surface
gravity which what's its metallicity and
we're able to show is it by just looking
at the variability in time over a couple
of different colors variable stars in a
certain part of the sky we're able to
infer the three properties I just
mentioned with as much accuracy as you
would get
from a low-resolution spectrum so it
turns the time-domain surveys like ztf
and LSST into these sort of low
resolution spectrographs so the way I
think about that is if you heard an
opera singer on the other side of the
door you could guess their gender that
one's pretty easy that's like
temperature you could guess their weight
and you could guess their age and be
accurate to about as well as you could
do if you're actually able to then go
and measure them directly so this is
very interesting
like the gamma ray burst project this is
only something that's worked so far in
retrospect we've yet to then apply this
to new surveys but this is one of the
things that we're hoping to do as new as
some of these new surveys come online
everything that I've mentioned so far
has been using you know what I'll call
kind of handcrafted features but there
are some real challenges with that
feature engineering for those that know
about that is very expensive and
oftentimes requires a lot of domain
knowledge so if you are trying to
separate two very similar types of
classes of variable stars oftentimes
you'll bring in the expert in that
domain or subdomain or sub sub domain
and try to build some math that encodes
what their brain is telling them of why
these two things are different
that's an expensive and iterative
process it's also a small data problem
where we don't have a lot to train on
and oftentimes the traditional machine
learning techniques don't account for
feature uncertainty and it's often very
difficult to apply one model to another
one to another survey so one of the
things that I'm excited to talk about
today is where we basically throughout
traditional feature engineering and we
used an auto encoding recurrent neural
net to basically create those features
for us in an unsupervised way so that is
where we don't need a whole bunch of
labels and for those that don't know
about auto-encoders the idea is actually
pretty simple you create an encoding
function which is demonstrated with this
e here of that light curve essentially
that raw data and then it's actually
probably pretty hard to see on the
screen
you basically compress that down to a
bottleneck which is a small number of
floating-point numbers like 64 numbers
and then you take that encoded small
number of data points and you decode it
so that you try to reproduce your
original light curve so without knowing
what this object is I can basically
build this if I get the architecture
right I can basically build this encoder
bottleneck decoder thing and then use
the bottleneck as features in a
traditional classifier and the this
encoding process actually works pretty
well these are some examples the raw
data is up at the top for two different
sources and for now just focus on the
red curve what you can see if we fold it
on the correct period of this source you
wind up seeing that the red points very
well match on the blue data so the
encoding and the decoding even though
it's a very lossy process winds up
producing some pretty nice-looking light
curves and what's cool about that is
something that we're able to demonstrate
in the paper where if we just had
sinusoids very noisy or regularly
sampled sinusoidal features essentially
it's like a small you know M dimensional
embedding we're able to show that those
features correlate very closely with the
things that we put in so we get period
out we get phase out get amplitude out
of these things and so what does that
mean it means that this network is
learning in this case here what it means
to be a periodic source and it learns
what it means to have a period of a
certain sort because we're taking what
is you know hundreds of data points and
compressing it effectively down to four
and in the context of astronomy what
we're doing there is we're not saying we
know this has got to have this period
it's got to have this amplitude it's got
to have this skewness and kurtosis it's
saying just learn the features that get
me back to my original source so the
cutting of the chase here we're able to
show that we rivaled sort of the
best-in-class results from all the hand
crafted feature engineering in two of
the three surveys we looked at we
basically beat all the other
best-in-class
sources and models so we're very excited
about this and what it means for us is
that we can instead of having to build
new features for every new for every new
survey we look at we can actually just
throw it into this machinery and use
that bottleneck layer as a way for us to
build features so for those ml folks in
the room and online here's the
architecture we used I think one of the
important things to point out is that
unlike other recurrent neural net
architectures were able to make explicit
use of the of the delta x between the
observations and we're also in our loss
function accounting for the inherent
uncertainties in the observation so if
you have one observation which is kind
of ratty and doesn't have a very good
measurement actually has a very large
error it won't adversely affect your ear
reconstruction and what's also nice
about this is we're able to augment our
data not buy as people do in the image
domain moving images around and shifting
them and changing pixels here and there
we're able to take the original light
curve data itself and essentially
bootstrap resample that light curve and
then actually wound up helping the
learning quite a lot and I think the
thing I'm kind of most excited about it
means that we can do on supervised
feature learning so instead of having to
learn features and build features by
hand we can leverage you know large
corpuses of unlabeled light curves to
build up these features and because that
bottleneck just becomes these abstract
features we can then use those and and
augment them with other sort of metadata
like colors etc I'll skip that for now
so let me just in the last few minutes
highlight some of the challenges and
open questions that we that we have one
of the things I'd love to spend time on
with the folks in the room is trying to
understand how we
find new phenomena so look at a
retrospective catalog and say are there
any clusters in some space that are
different than the types of objects we
already know about and I'd also like to
in a real-time mode as a new object is
just starting to develop not just
identify this is worth following up but
identify is this worth following up and
it's actually different than anything
we've ever seen before
we're different enough that's worth
spending even more resources on to learn
more another thing that I think is
interesting is this whole small data or
at least small label corpus problem and
the question there is you know how we
can leverage you know one model built on
one survey and apply it to another
survey that's transfer learning can we
even do better than then this sort of 4%
miss detection rate and they are you
know teams like at at Harvard Pablos
proto Papa's and his group are looking
at some unsupervised and semi-supervised
techniques what's interesting is that if
you think about the architecture that we
created for the classification problem
this is a very nonlinear nonparametric
model that can produce light curves of
realistic light curves of real objects
without me having to put the physics in
so can I use this sort of going the
other way and try to infer back the
physics for some of these objects whose
physics we actually know you know can I
use these as surrogates or emulators for
instance let's say in the gravitational
wave world it's extremely expensive to
generate a gravitational wave signature
with a few input parameters
computationally so you have these coarse
grids can you fill in those coarse grids
with with similar types of networks to
produce these emulators and can we use
these neural net models to be able to
help LSS LSST for instance figure out
what their Cadence's should be so if I
can now produce a fake universe of
transients of all different sorts you
can then actually create a cadence and
optimize on occasions to be able to find
those sources
and then systemic or systemic
optimization is probably beyond the
reach of of this group or anyone which
is optimized overall global resources
I'd love to be able to maximize the
scientific output but again we're in
this sort of competing mode where
different groups are all trying to get
access to similar telescopes I mean last
you know does this all have to be fully
automated or is there still a role for
people in the sort of real-time loop of
the real-time discovery certainly people
eventually will be the ones that write
the papers or at least for now
and if that doesn't happen you know
that'll be pretty exciting as well but
is there a role for people to be asked
questions from the model and say I think
it's one of these two can you do a
little bit of exploratory work give me
the answer then the model could wind up
updating itself so I'm generally curious
about that so let me end with a pretty
exciting discovery that was announced
just a couple of days ago where an
astronomer in Argentina was just turning
his telescope on for the first time and
the first thing you do is you look at a
beautiful galaxy and happened to catch a
supernova that was going off right in
the earliest stages the earliest stage
is pretty much we've ever seen and these
are the observations from that amateur
astronomer and then eventually
observations were taken later as in like
a day later and you know took a while
for the astronomer the amateur
astronomer to figure out that there was
this new source but you know this was
heralded as like winning the cosmic
lottery you turn on your facility you
look at something you find something
that shows up in nature you know a
couple years later or a couple of a year
later and people are very excited about
this rightfully so this is the earliest
parts of the evolution of a supernova
that we very very rarely get access to
but what I hope you've seen in the talk
today is that we shouldn't want to win
the lottery as astronomers right we want
to guarantee a nightly annuity of
essentially guarantees pay off and have
that be optimized not only over our
facility but globally
so I think that's an important point
we're trying to systematize discovery
and inference and it's very clear that
machine learning is becoming you know a
very very critical part of that whole
process so I'll stop there and I think
we've got time for just a few questions
so was that the GE the annuity yeah well
guaranteed payoff is much much nicer
than then you know every now and then if
you're lucky so I did it I wanted to
kick off with a question for you did you
learn anything interesting with the
things that you miss what was it
something missing in your model or was
the actual object that you were looking
at not exactly like the label on it
wasn't exactly yeah that's a good
question so you know the the
construction of a model or even more
broadly a system of software that and
that involves applying a model to data
and building that model you often wind
up holding out some of the sources that
you think you know the answer to and you
apply the model to that and and then you
measure how well you think you're doing
oftentimes you're extremely confident in
the model that this source is let's say
of type or Allari or supernova but the
label says something else that's all
that's either your models wrong which is
often the case or sometimes it's a cause
to go back and say was my label actually
right and so it actually can be a bit of
an iterative process for the miss labels
during this model construction process
where you go and you say did I actually
label that right or not and if you
labeled it right then your model was
wrong and the question is what can you
do in your model so that you don't get
that wrong again and what you do there
is potentially go back to the drawing
board and say what are the other
features that I'm missing right one of
the negatives of the sort of neural net
recurrent neural that auto-encoder
that I presented is that it becomes much
more of a black box you don't know what
those feet
did you add more features you make less
one of the benefits of the hand coded
features if you get something wrong you
can say oh I got it wrong because I
forgot to take an account that some of
these types of objects look like this at
the beginning even though most the ones
in my training set look like something
else so I'll just build an extra feature
that fits for that sort of thing so I
think though that's a long answer your
short question it's an iterative process
you either learn something about you
know how you're doing modeling and
ineffectively or you could learn
something fundamental about your data
now the real challenge is if you're
doing all this in an offline mode
because you've iterative ly sort of
rebuilt your model even on sort of held
out testing data you haven't really held
out your testing data as much as you
need to to gain a real good confidence
of what your ultimate uncertainties and
errors are going to wind up being once
you put this into a live mode so what I
generally say is that the only real
testing data is data that hasn't been
created yet ie the universe hasn't
evolved in the next second to produce
those objects so it's all very well a
nice to have
you know here's my false positive false
negative curve on paper the only real
machine learning system and astronomy
that you can trust is one that's
actually been put into production is my
contention
you mentioned the optimization global
optimization of follow-up we just as the
community just witnessed the largest
follow-up campaign ever conducted for a
source is there any evidence and your
opinion that there was suboptimal in the
Sun forum I think there was a that's a
great question so we just saw for those
in here it essentially the entire world
of astronomers going after one place in
the sky it was massively suboptimal you
know people were observing the same part
of the sky with the same sort of filter
at the same time now the nice part about
that is that we're really really sure
that the observations at that point in
time and that filter were right because
it wasn't one person saying it was ten
person saying so there is something nice
about that but there was very little
coordination I'd say and the next time
there should be more now what happens is
because these precious follow-up
resources like large telescopes are
indeed precious what you wind up seeing
is that the people that lord over those
like the directors of them wind up being
a bit of a playing referee and saying
well you guys shouldn't do it or
oftentimes more of a matchmaker and
saying you're all asking me for the same
observation you are now part of the same
group and so it's a very ad hoc a very
kind of real-time process of how these
collaborations wind up evolving it's
hard to see how we break out of that
model individual telescopes and
telescope consortium a pretty good job
of that recognizing they need to
optimize but globally I think this is
you know largely intractable problem not
technologically but more sociologically
politically the question I had was about
your encoder quickly three examples I
think we're all periodic so yeah not
this but I think the one after we have a
teef over you compared to more
traditional methods to this fancy oh
yeah so is this I mean I was curious how
this how this works for for media but
says it or not
and where even if the final answer is
not 90 something percent the traditional
Tesla is really do bad job so they could
they could be more dramatic improvement
it's a great question we focused on
periodic variables because there was the
largest corpus of label data that we
could find on those we are asking that
exact question on not just variable
stars but explosive sources there's a
new challenge coming out called the
plastic challenge which I'm sure you
know about which is for supernova and
transients some particularly non
variable stars of being able to classify
those so there's a group that's going to
be producing fake versions of all these
different types of objects and they're
asking the rest of the community can you
build a good classifier on that I think
the sort of network that we built can be
very applicable to those but we haven't
done the work yet to see how good those
are relative to the other classifiers
because that's what you don't know a
priori what the features that's that's a
that's right unfortunately you know a
lot of the very 8 periodic
stars are ones that just have sarcastic
variations and so there's other than
fitting you know power respect power
spectrum density distributions of like
what the variability is there's not a
whole lot of other features that you can
build certainly a periodic RAM doesn't
really make sense in that context but in
the context of like burbling quasars we
have built specific purpose-built
features knowing that quasar like curves
behave like damp random walks and so you
can get parameter fits out of those with
one question from the Twitter universe
Twitter universe
a question for you is it practical or
useful to apply a fine-tuning layer atop
your pre-trained of Auto encoding
neural-net
to apply it to new surveys a lot of
applications using an image now it's a
great question that's our supposition I
think we mentioned that a bit in the
paper but we haven't done the exercise
to take a pre train network on a large
survey and just say this network has
figured out something fundamental about
how variable stars work but it's not it
doesn't know a lot about this way in
which this particular data was taken and
this other survey let's apply it we have
taken the network we built on one survey
applied it directly to the other and it
worked really well just like when you
apply image net or vgg net to images
that aren't from that original corpus
you get very good answers but you're
right what you'd like to be able to do
is freeze some of the layers of the
model and then retrain some of the other
layers so that it learns some of the
peculiarities of that of that survey
this is a good question he's had his
hand up for a while from this one about
the follow-up for use of telescopes
resources that sounds an awful lot like
explosive exploits in behavioral ecology
which game theorists certainly the
notion of explore exploit is top of mind
you know in the groups that I've worked
in where you say I can either go after
let's say type 1a supernovae which if I
get enough of those it's a guaranteed
payout on some timescale exploit as in I
have a little moment in my telescope
follow-up resources where I don't have
anything scheduled why don't I go after
something I'm not sure what the answer
is what it hasn't been done is where
there's kind of an explicit discussion
identification of what the Explorer
exploit metrics are let alone the
adherence to those metrics because
oftentimes when you're on a telescope
and somebody hands you a basket of a
hundred objects that you could look at
you go man like that one that one's in
that
sky I don't like that part of the sky
right now where there's a cloud over
there so we haven't done a really good
job as a community I don't know any
groups that are being extremely explicit
about we are going to explore this
amount as in potentially waste a whole
lot of resources and exploit this amount
maybe take the rest offline yeah okay so
let's take our lunch break now and then
we'll come back at 1:30
[Applause]